i know
it's i i it's easier to make films
without simon um
because it's like
i think being being a sidekick this is
like my big chip on my shoulder being a
sidekick and a wingman
it's very difficult to
be taken
as anything but that for things you know
and so i think i've spent
i think successfully the last 10
[Music]
years or so trying to move myself away
from that right um i'm very grateful for
it
but
you know i thought there was potentially
i felt i could do more as a character
actor
um i felt i had it in me you know i
didn't want to just have all that
death in my life and then not
use it right uh
or use it to sell kind of little bits of
weed to
uh you know ed's friends right so you
know it's also difficult because it's
we work hard when we did those films we
weren't there there wasn't much laughter
i mean it was great to do and it was fun
but you're busting your ass it was
hard you know yeah there's we
just worked we worked we were cuz edgar
you know unfortunately we all shared a
similar work ethic in terms of let's
get it done let's do this you
know right yes it was fun
but the rehearsals were always fun
because then it was loose and we had
time and
and if something was funny and we all
laughed it would go in and then
that would be the shooting script you'd
use and then we only ever shot that we
didn't improvise we didn't
you know
but you yeah i mean
i i i also like the fact that edgar and
i and simon and i
have evolved our friendships have
evolved and because of that they they
have survived and there is you know
there is there is as much love there now
as there was
excuse me when we were 30 but now it's
like
i have three kids i have a partner we
have my
mom you know my
it your focus changing that's just
naturally what happens is you get as you
get older you know because if if you
if it doesn't you end up like
simon's character in the world's end you
know